ah this isn't a traditional dis December
video uh everything we are doing this
we're gonna do this as a sibling rivalry
because we have a lot of reviews that
this movie come here um we we got you
know this Disney December slide slipping
rivalry I'm going to do a bum review at
some point and there's another one
coming which i think is pretty obvious
what it is but i will not go into which
is in case you can't cast so we're just
number these two together we're also
gonna do a spoiler corner which we're
probably gonna talk more in that one
yeah but you want to know what we think
of the movie is not the video you're
looking for this is not the video you're
looking for you can go about your
business you can go about your business
you own your donor no kiss you a
doughnut thank you doesn't did you like
a doughnut patch or something oh you
know um what the jokes ruin now you they
really want to see the doughnut joke I'm
sure they'll want to know our opinions
at all um but yeah look at you you're
quite the little trooper aren't you I'm
actually a black guy under here even
know that I picked these cells of
trailers I yeah like the head though
it's very uh shine your boots Emperor
fish yeah you get your job your boots
Emperor have the people are British
anyway so it works except for the
stormtroopers that's what I don't get
the entire empires fucking British my
universes British um so which I don't
mind it the British actors are always
the best thing it's don't worry so uh
yeah they just give it like gave up this
time like you know what we're have the
main character be be yeah just make
Muslim British will make it foolproof so
um yeah so this is gonna be our spoiler
free it is flavor free we had of a
spoiler corner version so don't worry
about that that's gonna be a long yes
this is probably gonna be a short video
um honestly for me I can sum up this
movie in two words it's good it's it's
good um I I should also set up - I
wasn't like super hyped to see this
bounce like okay this looks like the
traditional Star
you know let's go I'm glad to see this
and stuff there's real things there
there's real monsters and aliens and
stuff like that which is great to see
and it's wonderful to see that and it's
good characters and some fun action and
stuff like that the story does move
forward um I'll go open more into that
probably in the spoiler corner but you
know it's it's good we'll enjoy your
trip to hell well I'm gonna give and and
what did you think with your story sure
for Hanna it was the most amazing thing
I see that was pretty good
like a real foster spring it yeah
actually it was it was pretty good I I'm
not gonna go out on a limb and say this
movie's perfect um but then again
considering the really low bar the
prequels set this may as well be citizen
fucking Kane yeah I mean that I you know
this is like The Godfather compared to a
Rob Schneider film so it's hard to kind
of judge
um but yeah there were moments that were
legitimately really great and then a lot
of it that was just good like I felt
like I could see this in any decent
movie that comes out any summer i
watching it all again without giving
anything away the first two-thirds of
this movie I felt like I'm watching Star
Wars you know I think it's critics we go
in thinking like all I want to look at
the technology I want to look at the
direction I will look at the camera
angles I want to say the music I wanna
and at some point I just sort of stop it
you know like not even consciously I
realized I was just sort of enjoying it
I was enjoying a cactus is usually the
other sphere third was very Star Wars
and then when they're in outer space for
a while and we'll talk about this in the
spoiler corner it was more like em like
as more like a JJ Abrams movie and then
they end up the characters end up going
to it's sort of Cantina type setting and
then it felt like Star Wars yeah so it
kind of was like
this mix but if you want the most salad
like oh this is just fucking Star Wars
that first third with rey on jakku or
whatever they call it was just amazing
and it was just there was very little
dialogue it was just her damn shit and
it still told us it with her putting the
marks on the wall showing how long she's
been there was a key yeah with her sort
of us you know being a scavenger in the
UM in those big ships and stuff like
that like and you've got how long she's
been doing it and who should communicate
with who she knows the fact that news
obviously doesn't travel much you get
her living conditions cuz she's like I
thought Luke Skywalker was a myth and
and for something like well come on
everybody had its technology phones then
come on yeah I know it's a gap so far
far away but then I realize I'm like no
she wouldn't have that a lot of people
here wouldn't happen that sets the
environment perfectly and it you know
what it reminds him it's like the
opening to Raiders of the Lost Ark
there's like no dialogue you get these
people very quickly that you get there's
no you is your en Jones there Indiana
Jones there was no dialogue given going
through these traps everything was set
up visually and then it eventually dumps
you into the story this was the same way
it set everything up about her vision
you understand man care very Wiggly
right away you you get fit very quickly
as well I'm not a single fucking mention
of the taxation of trade ha ha ha I
guess we're never going to find out what
happened to the taxation um all the girl
kid wasn't perfect we really grow you
know some of this I'll go into in the
spoiler corner but where the fuck did
this Empire come from I'm sorry it's
like they blow up to Death Star's and I
okay I guess they got to get it to the
first Death Star but then they make this
even bigger one now they have an even
bigger one and it's like no no they keep
coming back and I didn't even get an
idea I'm like so is does the Empire run
everything still or not because the good
guys okay though resistance okay I'm so
I'm totally glad you brought this up
yeah cuz I cuz I am gonna say something
I never thought I would say in my
fucking life but man did I need a George
Lucas style explanation of the politics
I'm very like that was my one of my few
complaints about this movie I'm just
like yeah what the fuck is going on you
know what you know I will balance that
out for you if I will probably take even
more heat for saying this cuz there is
actually something that Lucas did in the
prequels that I realize I did not see as
much here and I felt hurt the film but
this is my biggest problem with the film
again I'll go more into the spoiler
corner I thought there was too much
repeat literally from the beginning they
find a droid they give him information
they say this is important stuff to the
resistance that rebellion whatever and
the droid has to get there and from then
on really the basic story it's I mean
wow so yeah I could almost tell scene
for scene what was gonna happen it was
done well so I also thought I could sell
seriously the prequels where Domino okay
okay man tell me no no no I'm in a
little Aryan boy that the wiggle fucking
princess uh Queens something okay no
judge here here's the thing with the
prequels the one thing I realize
watching this I was just like you know
that you know you were talking about
Maggie some explanation of this politics
I could use just a totally different set
up because that is the one thing I
realized with the other fields as much
as they're not good and they suck it was
something completely different you know
Luka said it wasn't yeah yes it wasn't
nobody could look at it like the Phantom
Menace would be like oh yeah that was
Star Wars you know it's something that's
just like totally batshit crazy you're
different and it wasn't nothin oh there
a side shit that was different but the
basics of the story right down to Ted I
mean this fucking that Jabba the Hutt
and it still no no no happens no no hey
here's some characters blob what's the
plot I mean oh it's still hard to figure
out but yeah there's some sort of
political thing going on
there's no Empire there's some sort of
war being fought but it's hard to follow
so they go and they find this boy that
barely has like mythical powers and some
to talk about training em or do they not
but good guys are in control that's a
gun
different girl stop stop that is your
plot you can't take me seriously of the
zinger I love it now it's okay you just
said it there they find some new boy on
some dirt water planet with the princess
or whatever it it's like an insane
number man and should he go on a journey
now there was one of the things you said
that is the plot right there and that is
also the plot to guess what
Oh fucking oh I always say well well
first of all I know he goes there and
he's like if he knows he wants to be
trained he knows he has this tree I mean
it's you know you he comes across the
master and everything and yeah actually
he's killed him that too does anything
see here's the thing here's the thing
both then maybe I recognize it lesson
the other film so this one both
trilogies and this one is doing the
exact same fucking thing are running on
ring theory you're just going to see the
same thing again and again that is
literally what this is if you want to
complain about a gym oh I hate ring
theory I hate seeing this I just don't
like this type of story that's fine you
don't have to like this type of story
but to pretend that oh well this film is
doing it but the first trilogy then
video from the minute maybe because the
other field the prequels got so lost in
its madness and look so entirely
different I was at using in blood one no
no but you know what you are right it is
still I mean however however heat the
good guy the cool uncle main character
does not have a happy ending in that so
at least you know that's going in
different directions things gonna go bad
but I mean you know that just the basic
plot layout of this film is like almost
scene for scene
a new hope I mean where the first one
had sort of a basic story this is almost
scene for you but I can't really talk
about that here alright re well look
into that the spoiler corner but let's
just say it's all it's not just the new
hope this movie pretty much encapsulate
the entire freakin original trilogy it's
a I just want I just got to see items
well it's repeating already it's already
covered in my opinion - Wow okay that is
kind of true with some of the reveals
and stuff idea what we'll get into that
but here's my thought though is that
even though
a lot on repeat in my opinion uh it's
done well and the characters are good
and the acting is good I was telling him
uh India Jones Crystal Skull I really
hoped you liked that alien and crystal
skull Cassie's the doing okay there's my
boy Cooper go into that barn waiter but
um uh so but Harrison Ford um you know
when you see him in Kingdom was gone ya
know when you see my king of Crystal
Skull you see okay here's a guy who
hasn't done this in a while and is
trying to add like India Jones is kind
of overconfident say let's also remember
script by David camp yes and that didn't
help anything either this film I mean
honestly the past couple films with
Harris before I felt like he's been
trying to overcome it
I'm really tough not of my life and it's
been kind of awkward so this film I mean
like it's an older version of Han Solo
but it's still Han Solo I just
immediately like I get this is solo I'm
watching Han Solo and that was really
really cool and same thing when you see
lay a general Leia now I mean I just fan
I'd seen Leia like oh these are still
the same characters and these are seem
to see still the same a there's a doing
it every way
yeah pretty easily I have a lot of that
I think is good writing for them to any
really good dialogue forum and yeah I
say there are some there are detours but
not as much as say Return of the Jedi
um but they are there's the middle part
of the movie gets a little high are you
talking about when they're on the on the
freighter yeah yeah I'm like I'm like
okay this is just kind of random now
like I don't know how this better that
felt very Lucas you know you know I know
you know worried this I'm like oh this
is one of those distractions that kind
of goes nowheres well if it was Lawrence
Kasdan's way of going you know let's
just throw in a march to George in here
and just get really random for about 20
minutes
um but yeah I might only I mean my two
biggest criticisms one the the supreme
leader overlord
pretty lame hi I am I am horrified down
in it not just have
that's all right it's not quite hot I am
horrified that damn right confused that
anybody on this project fucking green
let those effects it is some of the
shittiest CGI
I have seen of them people like Jurassic
world go after him you like the effects
of Dressel group go after it here's your
chance here's your check I did I know
and I'm just saying like not all the CGI
in this movie sucks there's a lot of no
there's a lot of good the fact though it
was like that was a crappy Jabba the
Hutt special edition worthy shit and
here's the thing to see this wasn't an
interesting character designer looking
in my opinion at all he just looks like
some withered old version of Palpatine
or something it really on that knife I
think you've helped you given that way
too much it was just a ridiculous nut
snare already that was I thought was
amazing yeah all so I I thought he was
very well done I thought the basic
design was very good the voice was good
sweet like I know you have to have the
whole kind of cific but I was kind of
hoping he would just be in charge and he
would be the supreme ya know I was going
home baby with two um which and what
they're doing with the character I'm
like when I saw their joy I'm like okay
I'm fine with this you know I don't know
wrong with this um whatever I also had
my other minor criticism as I was saying
like I need some explanation what's
going on because okay there's the the
first order the the new order whatever
that basically Empire light the Empire
is coming back diet Empire same great
taste it's not even light it's like ten
times bigger like what the thing they
make like yeah okay that's putting all
your eggs in one basket I didn't get the
impression here's the thing when you
look at like Empire Strikes Back yeah
you had the one Death Star but you also
had a fucking fleet like yeah the
executor but that definition and demonic
anchor but thinking no no think about
we've got what are we see in this film
it's like one Star Destroyer with a
bunch of troops on board and this planet
Death Star II in like that's kind of it
so I get the feeling like this is the
remnants that have like put all of their
eggs and kind of this one super basket
like which did they do that before
well then this this is where it should
be the ring theory gets a little old for
me to where I'm just like okay well I've
seen that but hey so you've got that
you've got this this new empire but they
keep referencing the New Republic so I'm
like okay so the New Republic there but
then on top of that they're like in the
resistance and that's where I got
confusing like okay who the fuck's the
resistance yeah and then late I don't
think this is a spoiler
we know Leah's in this film so and I
think you could put it together in the
trailers you know leah is basically
working for the good guys and she's part
of this resistance I'm like well how is
any disrelated to the new republic yeah
I like the politics of this I'm like how
what universe is it where I want a
better explanation of the politics of
the Star Wars go me but and I'm sure the
youtubers will go nuts explaining it to
me now but I just didn't get it the
first time watching this movie that is
something I've never had to complain
about before them you know Star Wars
film so what and I think that the idea
of like another evil coming back even
taking out the Ring cycle thing I mean
it's like we see then we see
dictatorships taken down and you know
evil evil people destroying stuff like
that by either followers or people that
want to start new terrible dictatorships
that you know can come in or they can go
to other places and stuff so
fair enough I'm not against that it's I
need to me it's like how did they get
how they get this big I mean this big
well and you never see can't I mean is
I've never done it complain about like
well you never see the New Republic in
what their life is like that much so are
they kind of corrupt now is is the
Empire like are they like Donald Trump
now they're kind of gathering up all the
suckers of the world and they like it
there just was no kind of explanation
where they're just there it may be again
like I feel like it's almost like an
apology for the prequels like well we
can't do that again you know this film
is so nobody got so bored but I think
they were so concerned about that that
they lift up just some basic thing this
film is so good at visually telling its
story I think they could have found a
way to give an idea how things are
whatever in the new government new
republic whatever without showing my
mages a little
newscast or something like that or
President Lee detective whatever just
something to give us a basic idea oh I
think like that part of it and this is
the difference this is what takes
getting used to is the fact that this is
an Abrams movie and don't get me wrong
some of it feels like Star Wars oh yeah
it feels like sours again but even
within the realm of George Lucas as much
as the prequels felt separate from the
original Star Wars you can still tell
Lucas's fingerprints are on it and this
one is really you can tell Lawrence
Kasdan's fingerprints are all over this
magic Later but you know it it just
feels a little different in the
direction for one thing there's actually
lens flares almost else's anything like
a war movie yeah and I thought overall
it was really good and there was nothing
bad about it I'm like these are actually
really nice kind of fun shots and it
does put you in there but it definitely
doesn't have that classic Star Wars feel
definitely like okay this is an Abrams
thing and Abrams interprets yeah I
thought about half and half I thought
about half Abrams have kind of a classic
Star Wars bi-ig a lot of time really
felt like okay this is Calle Green but I
want to it's a hundred but it still
feels different
yeah like it still it's half and half
and that's not necessarily a negative
it's just something we all have to get
used to Rex's I do I don't I don't like
to be a little more different but again
the Ring cycle and I think it's
something of a story I'm talking about
the way it's shot and fell okay yeah and
I mostly this the the pacing of it this
ties in I think that what we're talking
about you know is the one kind of
negative and the way that the politics
wasn't explained the pacing of it and
this is something I've never really
gotten you know and I did get it out of
a Lucas movie that's the weakest one
attack the clones in the tank of clones
I never had any kind of concept of why
any of this shit was important or who
gave a crap and I don't get it as bad
here but one thing that I never would
charge Lucas of particularly in the
original trilogy was not knowing how to
milk something like the first Death Star
battle you
new every day at state you know the
plans are important you knew how this
was going to go down that last 20
minutes like everything felt important
in Empire you knew they were being
chased you knew it was that said you
knew bigger was going to try and fit
felt important Jedi same thing
everything felt important to milked in
this film we're doing kind of Star Wars
it just kind of it's very strange I kind
of feel like it just wasn't milked
enough like you've got this giant planet
and you've got x-wings going against him
is then I feel like it's just kind of
stuff happening it's when you you see it
a million times I mean it's just the it
might be the weakest part of this movie
again without going into too much
details like the last 20 minutes which I
think you said fry your favorite I'll
see to me it's it's by far the weakest
cuz I thought it was just I could tell
everything was gonna happen it was pure
repeat uh and except nothing there
wasn't enough new stuff that was added
on top of it that wasn't already set up
and immersing came back alive that's
what it's suddenly all of a sudden felt
important like up until that point I
felt like hey here's a bunch of random
stuff that's everything kind of Attack
of the Clones feeling of like I guess I
didn't get the importance of it all is
like the last 20 minutes it felt like it
just switched on to be like oh so now we
kind of know what's it's Stacey to me I
felt like we moms we can't go into it
we're gonna have shits laying around
because of Star Wars we have a
lightsaber Bell cuz at Star Wars we
stuff that happens this farm a corner
all we have to add because it's Star
Wars I mean that's all I felt throughout
that last 20 min until literally the
last minute and I thought well what's
cool again we'll go into it but that was
really cool maybe your problem is you
shouldn't see a movie called Star no I
don't I don't like the fact that some
things you know you have to have cuz of
Star Wars but then when you just feel
like the whole story the whole set up we
have to just do the repeat because of
Star Wars that bothers me because that
becomes boring that becomes stale and
like you said it's not exciting I
thought so much of what they were
setting up early on was exciting but
also felt like stories at Star Wars and
it just feels like okay well we're doing
it not because we have a really cool
story to tell but because it's Star Wars
I have a problem at all the only thing I
had a problem with was
whole x-wing battle thing I'm just like
yeah like I think we maybe we've just
run out of ideas with what to do with
that swings for a while in battles
against Death Star like things but it
that was the only part of that the rest
of it on the ground which we'll go into
I thought was fantastic and gorgeously
shot yeah it was um gorgeous looking I
really like the way that's real it felt
mythic again like epic but not a met oh
there's like a thousand guys firing
lasers sort of wait but people with
frickin laser swords like it should be
in a battle over Souls and the dark and
light side of them like that's what I
liked about the original Star Wars and
that's what I gotta get and they set up
a few things in the middle of this that
you know they're gonna go into in the
other movies that I was thinking like
wow that's like really different and
really diving deep into this if I was
like I I'm intrigued I really want no
more about this and maybe I thought they
were gonna go more that direct instead
just oh yeah they're a big ball to blow
up okay um but I think that the one last
thing I'll say but I probably before we
we should read this idea of the spoiler
corner is that um the animatronics and
the stuff that's really there and I'll
even better make a bigger in for the
computer of the effectiveness are
wonderful um except for this approver
there's the only that sticks no no I'll
even make an argument that when CG I
don't you're off computers are
everywhere in movies now I get it
and they're even in places where we
don't notice it and you need them
computers are very important and
wonderful artwork has been done with
them and stuff like that and one of our
work is done here as well but when you
get to characters main characters now
that art completely CG yeah you have
this Emperor character and then you have
this woman who I think Ramba Katina when
I stage running yeah uh yeah is she
comes into this coastal cities yeah and
I'm seeing myself all these creatures
and these creations look phenomenal why
did those two need to be CG nothing
about them required CG you could have
done that with makeup I mean II would
have been comfortable on a person
whatever but you could have had the eye
show through and everything and I'm
realizing that I'm realizing that with
this I got spoiled with all the stuff
that was really there and even though I
know computers digitally up this and
filling this and stuff like that I caps
play with that the majority was really
there that when the computers did come
and it felt really distracting and the
fight that if I if I could go back and
do a special edition of this movie I
would replace the CG those two CG
characters with real people you know I
would do the anti special edition the
supreme leader bothered me because I
think it's legitimately a crappy effect
like it even within the even I know we
always say all CGI looks fake to us but
even within that bar that's when's that
I don't think I look good I thought she
was fine I actually know shit she
reminded me of when I did by the end of
it I still always prefer puppet Yoda but
by the end of it what we got in Revenge
of the Sith with Yoda I thought was
pretty sound yeah it wasn't the same
thing with golem and Lord of the Rings
and so I actually like her I thought the
character animation on her was great
don't you need is really I let me set
that straight she if there's a lot of
emotion there's a lot of carrot there's
a lot of acting bears there and a great
voice actress and stuff ah tensed yeah
no no and you know I mean there probably
was like a real person there been
filling for her and stuff and they just
CG the face but I think because all the
stuff that was really there was really
there they had such expression in such a
motion and stuff like that when you see
the CG moving the wrinkles and you know
sir smudging and moving and that's how
they get the emotions it it suddenly
became distracting I think in any other
movie I would have been fine with it but
I think because there was so much of the
real stuff there it threw me off a bit
hey I didn't pick anybody yeah yeah I
didn't get that from her at all
especially on the close-ups and stuff if
it throws me off of it but it's either
it's like you can't win because it's
either do the whole movie with practical
effects which I think that ship is
saying yeah much as I would love to go
back 11 my friend
you know that ship a sail or do the
entire thing CGS
why why can you do both that fast we
don't know majority of the characters in
this you know once or twice you see a
background character at CG or a robot so
the majority the ones are up there were
really up there and only the tiniest
touches you know for the CG and at least
it felt like uh so I'm saying that you
know on something like that where you
have to really focus on this woman's
face and her eyes and stuff like that
you know what why did that necessarily
need to be CG unless they thought they
could do like another Gollum you know
possibly if you make their character
endearing another thing animate the
character will not put enough heart and
soul into it
I do think CGI can be like like not
necessarily better but like puppetry oh
no it is not the truth but I didn't have
a complaint because I thought it was so
solid you know other things that I
haven't liked in Star Wars with cj's
because it looks like the fucking Jabba
the Hutt scene in the special edition
just a fake
you know this even in this movie the
supreme leader I thought look think her
character where are we but what the hell
was her name you remember him that's a
problem with the Star Wars aliens names
are also weird yeah her character though
I thought was so endearing that I just
forgot about her like when she squinted
her eyes I I felt it was there enough
that I just got lost in the character I
don't get how that the CG yeah that's
probably just a me thing then honestly I
mean it dumping asleep or not it doesn't
it doesn't ruin anything I honestly I
was saying that because there was so
much practical effect in there that I
was actually sort of feeling like almost
jaded off the computer stuff but again I
know the computer stuff has to be there
it is there a lot of it looks gorgeous
but I'm probably not even realizing is
okay well order the Rings there were a
fuck ton of practical effects in that
guys in latex mask that he built big
atures you know instead of just CGI
everything else I call oh my god so yeah
that didn't bother you you seemed okay
with that no ah doesn't principal know
that that is very true I think because
maybe cuz there was
there's a lot CG in this too I mean I'll
say only because there was so many CG
lands on this like if you want if you
want to know what bothers me the most if
we're talking CGI just generally in
principle it's all the model shots like
the CGI Millennium Falcon as much as I
try to be like get sucked into it and
there are scenes that are great with the
Falcon than this I'm just like yeah just
still looks like a cartoon to me like I
can't ever get over and that's because
like I've never thought CGI is captured
the models of the stuff for spaceships
quite like those original junky models
you know up but I mean the thing is it
didn't wreck the movie for me but if
we're talking where CGI for me just
still is yet to really totally work it's
partly that and I think that's partly
because the old-school shots had like an
old-school feel to where you had to use
the motion control cameras so they were
storyboarded beautifully in this man you
know nowadays and this is way less than
I think in the prequels but it's still
there these shots are so overly
complicated that I get kind of lost them
like I miss the simplicity of the old
Star Wars you know you know I thought
the action in this movie was only okay
which I've in mind because again the
focus should be on the characters and
the story and stuff like that ah I
remember like a memorable action
sequence in this and I really can't like
even the sword battle Bing Bing Bing
where is he I I remember the sword
battle and I remember the Falcon I'm err
the characters say they wouldn't yeah
good basically your your trailer shots I
remembered that really well mm um there
was no Death Star battle like anything
even remotely close to Endor or Yavin
for when it so yeah in that sense you're
right and I think that's where it was a
little bit of a must just the last 20
minutes of movie I thought it flipped on
that was the one thing where it still
did them and here's like it's literally
like a handful of X wings just flying
around just blowing little things up
it's there's some X we a like it it's
not quote unquote bad or anything but
it's very basic but that's really that's
not why I come to see Star Wars I can go
see Fast and Furious to see great actors
I'm just are looking here
horn I am fuckin loved every care yeah I
did well the first time I'm like I'm
really sucked in to the world these
people live in these people's lives
their character their journey and
there's a mystery - yeah I like yeah
it's slowly revealing and then we're
gonna find out more in the other films
which I really enjoy so yeah it did I
think it's good chick in the lead -
that's their - my original choice from
the original trilogy but I always felt
that somehow Leia got a little bit
cheated like she starts off in the first
one is like badass and she's still kind
of has it's like when the third one it's
going there Java side them and fire some
blaster occasions like that's not ray
she's like running around doing
everything this one the nice thing -
again how there's only two women and you
know in the original trilogy this woman
everywhere there's people of every
different ethnicity you can imagine
everywhere there's people of you know
there's scottish there's british there's
asian there's black I neither there's
everything in there uh which is nice I
mean it's one of those things for it's
like we always get kind of like the
token ones in the original trilogy and
they were favored yeah don't say my gosh
it's like we got a black guy and yeah
really
yeah but I mean you know it's one of
those things where it's like yeah we had
the original trilogy but it is really
nice man so now they're like the focus
they're the lead that you know the Star
Wars universe looks like a universe it
doesn't look like you know some white
people and a ton of creepy we're looking
it doesn't look like white Shakespeare
in the Park
yeah it's are looks like if I could you
know you see all these different aliens
everywhere then just like nothing but
white men it's like wow man white men
seem to be the only ones that made it
out of there was various Black Guard in
Phantom Menace let's not forget Londo
was really important he betrayed the
good guys this is al of land Asia I know
where those amazing how's that sir we
hope you keep with a shot hey Peter
welcome to the cool side of the pillow
if Lando shows up in this I that would
be amazed
I hope he shows in the second one cuz
he's awesome uh so yeah that's a general
gist there is that it was good I think
you liked it more than I did
I generally what do you say it's yes
just the Ring cycle or they're just
repeating so that you know because they
feel they have to because of Star Wars I
the repetition got to be a little bit
but uh it's good I'm looking forward to
seeing where they're gonna go from here
and a little off on you just can't like
something enough can you like it that's
not enough obviously this is the
Internet my page is a Star Wars I know I
I thought it was really good I I'm not
gonna say was perfect or great it I
don't know it's too soon to say where I
would rank it but definitely above the
prequels so yeah you know whether it's
better than the other three like I can't
even say it cuz I'm still digesting it I
will say this I want to see it again
totally I would totally see it again
right now so in fact I probably will I
probably have enough time them yeah I
can make a miniature that's good so cool
that's about it as you all know we
thinking spoiler corny can definitely
click on that until then um live long
and prosper dude